ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom and liberty
and the american dream the best
is yet to come the 2020 republican
national convention
kicked off on monday and proved to be a
major talking point for celebs who hit
up twitter to reflect on the night's
fiery speeches this election is a battle
for the soul of america
your choice is clear one speaker who
stirred up
a lot of chatter online was kimberly
guilfoyle
the girlfriend of donald trump jr who
also happens to be the ex-wife of
california governor gavin newsom
if you want to see the socialist biden
harris future for our country
just take a look at california it is a
place of immense wealth
immeasurable innovation an immaculate
environment
and the democrats turned it into a land
of discarded heroin needles and parks
riots and streets and blackouts in homes
kimberly delivered a super enthusiastic
speech
which brian greenberg described as so
very loud and bette midler well she
referenced donald trump
writing kimberly guilfoyle knows her
future father-in-law loves all caps
so that's how she did her speech
meanwhile
others seem to take offense at the
actual content of her speech
as a first generation american i know
how
dangerous their socialist agenda is
my mother mercedes was a special
education teacher from aguadilla puerto
rico
my father also an immigrant came to this
nation in pursuit of the american dream
now i consider it my duty to fight to
protect
that dream sunny hostin said she was
horrified
and embarrassed as a fellow latina
calling into question her claims that
she is a first generation american
because her mom is from puerto rico
which is a u.s
territory every american must be free to
live
without fear of violence in your country
in your communities
and in your homes all men and women are
created equal and must be treated
equally under the law
trump jr also delivered an impassioned
speech which
addressed the civil unrest in the wake
of the death of george floyd
we must put an end to racism and we must
ensure that any police officer who
abuses their powers
is held accountable what happened to
george floyd is a disgrace and if you
know a police officer you know they
agree with that too
and at the same time the 42 year old
praised the work of police officers
arguing the importance of law and order
we cannot lose sight of the fact that
our police are american heroes
they deserve our deepest appreciation
because no matter what the democrats say
you and i both know
when we dial 9-1-1 we don't want it
going to voicemail
so defunding the police is not an option
he went on to praise his dad's
administration
particularly trump's response to the
coronavirus
he spent a lot of a speech detailing the
differences in policies and practices
between his dad and democratic
presidential candidate joe biden
he painted a bleak picture of what he
thinks the biden presidency
might look like biden's radical
left-wing policies
would stop our economic recovery cold
he's already talking about shutting the
country down
again it's madness and while many celebs
took
jabs at kimberly and trump jr outspoken
conservative commentators praised a
speech from former football star
herschel walker i watched him treat
janitors
security guards and waiters the same way
he retreated vip
he made them feel special because he
knew they were
herschel spoke about his longtime
friendship with the president
and vouched for his integrity if you
love america and want to make it better
donald trump is your president he's my
president
and i'm blessed to call him friend